mais bon on te ville bonjour bonjour
monsieur car oui bonjour aux auditeurs
de martinique 1ère ancien bâtonnier de
l'ordre des avocats de la martinique
avocat à la cour vous êtes également le
président de l'institut d'études
judiciaires de la martinique et
l'institut des droits de l'homme de la
martinique
donc qui est maintenant bien inscrit
dans notre paysage sociétal j'ai envie
de dire puisque l'institut des droits de
l'homme de la martinique a fêté ses dix
ans d'existence l'an dernier vous pouvez
nous rappeler les objectifs initiaux
alors on va juste corriger une petite je
suis pas président de l'institut
d'études judiciaires de la martinique sé
bann de boké directrice de voeckler de
bourran de l'air de bons aliments
universitaire agrégé des facultés de
droit effective et moi je suis président
de l'institut des droits de l'homme de
la martinique qui a fêté au mois de juin
de l'année dernière son dixième
anniversaire l'institut des droits de
l'homme de la martinique a pour vocation
de d'oeuvrer pour une meilleure
connaissance et une meilleure pratique
des droits de l'homme en martinique
alors comme le logo symbolise très bien
l'institut des droits de l'homme et
ouvert sur la martinique parce que des
droits de l'homme ne s'enferme pas dans
un territoire mais les doigts de l'homme
s'exerce aussi sur un territoire
donc nous avons nous sommes très ancré
sur le territoire martiniquais et c'est
pour ça que nous appelons institut des
droits de l'homme de la martinique alors
de ce point de vue il n'y a pas de
préoccupation particulière à avoir au
niveau du respect des droits humains ici
singulièrement martin ici on disait cela
on pourrait dire qui a pas de problème
de droits de l'homme en france puisque
la france est la patrie des droits de
l'homme au ce serait une vue de l'esprit
parce que le respect des droits de
l'homme c'est un objectif
un objectif c'est comme l'horizon et
c'est le combat pour le respect des
droits de l'homme
c'est un combat de tous les jours parce
qu'en réalité l'homme c'est un loup pour
l'homme
des lots qui a deux hommes l'un en face
de l'autre un moment ou un autre il ya
une tentation d'empiéter sur le doigt de
l'autre non en réalité tous les jours il
dit
des violations des droits de l'homme et
tous les jours il y à se battre pour le
respect des droits de l'homme alors une
des missions aussi c'est d'organiser des
manifestations de toutes natures
encourager la publication d'études ou de
travaux relatifs justement aux droits de
l'homme aux droits humains parce que
l'on dise droits de l'homme c'est faut
prendre l'homme dans son acception
général c'est l'homme déjà fan donc
certains préfèrent utiliser l'expression
droits humains et puis donc organiser
des conférences grand public se saisir
aussi de certaines préoccupations
d'actualité un des problèmes qui
touchent pas on va y revenir par exemple
mais la conférence du 3 mai on a d'abord
parlé de celle de vendredi de cette
semaine mais vous avez en perspective la
vulnérabilité de la population
martiniquaise face aux risques naturels
majeurs par exemple absolument on va y
revenir donc vous saisissez aussi de
problèmes très actuel qui concerne donc
la société martiniquaise
mais c'est bien ça c'est vous vous avez
repris d'ailleurs votre cycle de
conférences de conférences grand public
et donc y en aura une ce vendredi c'est
aussi votre votre mission vraiment
contact de de la population va en fait
nous avons comme un corps humain de pied
un pied qui est la réflexion et les
qu'une ce sont les conférenciers des
libertés et des droits fondamentaux pour
cette activité nous sommes jumelés avec
l'institut d'études judiciaires de la
menthe unique et nous offrons donc des
conférences de qualité universitaire
mais à la portée de tous nous avons un
deuxième pied qui ce deuxième pièce ce
sont les commissions
nous avons une commission développement
durable en martinique
pareil j'ai pas développement durable en
général développement durable a menti ni
nous avons une commission doit la prison
réfection sur la prison en martinique et
nous avons une commission santé en
martinique
dans ce cadre là et comme nous avons
mission devrait en collaboration avec
toute institution qui s'intéressent de
près ou de loin aux doigts de l'homme
nous partageons parfois nos réflexions
avec d'autres acteurs de la société
martiniquaise
les conférenciers des libertés des
droits fondamentaux à l'univers
des facultés de droit en collaboration
avec dj les réflexions ça peut être avec
d'autres institutions et notamment là
nous allons travailler avec le csm qui
est le conseil de la culture de
l'environnement etc
l'instance consultative auprès de la 7e
et pour cette réflexion nous allons
travailler avec le professeur ça fâche
si les disques majeurs on va on va y
revenir on aura l'occasion d'en parler
évidemment sur sur notre antenne mais
avant cette conférence du 3 mai il y à
celle du 29 mars donc de vendredi
prochain vendredi de cette semaine
raymond ville président de l'institut
des droits de l'homme de la martinique
est donc là par contre c'est une
conférence qui a rapport avec l'histoire
notre histoire puisque le thème c'est
des sociétés d'esclaves en martinique
aux 18e et 19e siècles et ce sera donc
animée par une professeure retraitée de
lettres et d'histoire-géographie madame
martine flandry n'a alors que vous savez
une fois par un au moins nous faisons
une conférence que j'appelle
transversale puisque c'est pas une
conférence de droit c'est pas une
conférence d'histoire c'est pas une
conférence deuxio graphiste une
conférence de tous en même temps
en plus nous essayons de fait à cette
conférence le plus près possible du 22
mai parce que comme nous faisons ces
conférences à l'université nous devons
tenir compte du calendrier universitaire
et la maintenance et le calendrier des
examens c'est notre dernière conférence
à l'université nous devons laisser
l'amphithéâtre frantz fanon pour les
examens dorénavant et cette conférence
transversale a toujours pour objectif de
nous permettre une petite introspection
sur nous mêmes parce que nous nous
sommes rendu compte que si nou matinik
et nous ne faisons pas ces trois sièges
sur nous-mêmes et nous ne pouvons pas
compter sur les autres pour faire ce que
nous ne faisons pas et qui nous
intéresse finalement ce qui nous touche
de près c'est nous qui devons nous en
occuper précisément vraiment hauteville
quel est l'intérêt
aujourd'hui en 2019 de s'intéresser aux
sociétés d'esclaves en martinique aux
18e et 19e siècles parce qu'en fait nous
parlons de la réalité de notre réalité
d'aujourd'hui
la réalité d'aujourd'hui c'est que en
réalité un être humain ne tombe jamais
du ciel comme un ovni
il vient d'une terre il vient d'une
histoire
il vient d'un pays il vient d'une
culture au aujourd'hui tout le monde
connaît le crédit mutuel mais tout le
monde connaît les sociétés mutualistes
mais savez-vous que l'origine vient dé
ces sociétés d'esclaves et pourquoi
parce que les maîtres et la colonie
interdisait tout rassemblement
d'esclaves ils avaient peur des révoltes
et donc il était interdit
ces esclaves qui étaient considérés
comme des animaux ont passé leur temps à
montrer qu'ils ne sont pas des animaux
mais qu'ils sont des êtres humains et
dans le réduction à l'état minimal
d'animal ils ont fait vivre l'humanité
qui est en eux ils sont réussis à ceux à
ceux à tromper l'ennemi par des réunions
musicale ils ont à l'occasion de ses
résultats une union musicale les les
roses les soirées délai légal en dha etc
il discutait il ya entre deux danses y
discuter vraiment ils ont réussi à se
réunir ils ont réussi à s'organiser et
se sont donc ça les sociétés d'esclaves
et ceci de la finalité de ces sûr
c'était de ces regroupements des stades
ça a été les tontines voilà où ce qu'on
appelait aussi le sous le sceau c'est la
routine
saïd et les sociétés de caution mutuelle
qui a fait ça s'appelait pas qu'aux
mitschek le doigt du d'aujourd'hui mais
l'origine
eh ben ça que ça c'était aujourd'hui on
a besoin d'un coup de main bondonneau
connaît à celui là ça peut être un
travail ça peut être enfouis en légumes
après ça ici en argent après ça a été on
se réunit et donc c'est l'origine des
sociétés d'entre aide mutuelle
c'est l'origine des sous c'est l'origine
est en réalité si l'origine du crédit
mutuel c'est donc cet état d'esprit
c'est ensuite transmis au fil des ans
et qui ont donné donc et ses mutuelles
effectivement pas seulement ces
mutuelles c'est l'association pendant un
moment on était les antilles était
délétère où il y avait au kilomètre
carré le plus d'associations et donc
c'est donc notre histoire et cette
histoire là il nous faut la connaître
bon bah écoutez ce sera passionnant donc
ce sera vendredi soir de 18 heures à 20
heures dans l'amphithéâtre frantz fanon
donc de la faculté de droit et
d'économie
la martinique sur le campus de
schoelcher cette conférence grand public
les sociétés d'esclaves en martinique
aux 18e et 19e siècles
organisée par l'institut d'études
judiciaires la martinique et l'institut
des droits de l'homme de la martinique
raymond hauteville
donc on l'a dit on va parvenir on a
signalé que la prochaine ce sera à la
salle plénière de l'hôtel de la
collectivité territoriale à plateau roy
cluny le vendredi 3 mai la vulnérabilité
de la population martiniquaise face aux
risques naturels majeurs avec le
professeur pascal ça fâche
dites moi en quelques mots puisque on a
peu de temps puisque vous saisissez un
petit peu d des problèmes bertic
justement qui touche le les droits de
l'homme bon le transport vous avez déjà
eu l'occasion d'en parler par le passé
la santé publique etc
mais là les jeunes là il ya eu un drame
absurde qui s'est produit si c'est
vraiment le cas si c'était des jeunes
qui jouaient avec une arme chargée et un
coup de feu est parti
tu es un des jeunes ça c'est par exemple
un des sujets donc vous pouvez vous
servir vous saisir ce souci de sécurité
qui touche en particulier les plus
jeunes de la population alors le sujet
c'est bien voilà aussi bien moins la
sécurité que l'éducation parce que en
réalité
victor hugo disait vous ouvrez une école
vous fermer une prison c'est exactement
ça plus on est moins là l'éducation -
informations - l'élévation du niveau de
l'esprit et est importante plus on est
dans la dérive et dans des atteintes
physiques ou morales contre l'homme très
bien l'avocat je vous êtes aura
certainement l'occasion de communiquer à
nouveau sur ce sujet dramatique qui
touche notre société bonne journée à
tous merci beaucoup aux aquarelles vont
tomber
tv5 a dit